bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
de réécouter l'audition d'Hervé falsani
cet informaticien ancien employé d'HSBC
à Genève est à l'origine des révélations
sur la gigantesque fraude fiscale on
parle de 180 milliards d'euros une
fraude organisée par la banque cette
enquête baptisée Swiss leaks est basée
sur les fichiers de la banque HSBC
suisse des fichiers volés en 2007 par
Hervé faltiani il les a ensuite remis
aux autorités françaises et grâce à ces
fichiers le fisque français aurait d'ors
et déjà récupéré
231 millions d'euros alors Hervé falsen
a été auditionné en 2013 par la
commission d'enquête spéci
du Sénat sur le rôle des banques dans
l'évasion fiscale une commission
demandée par le groupe communiste au
Sénat c'est cette audition les
explications d'Hervé falsen que je vous
propose de réécouter tout de
suite bien mes chers collègues nous
commençons cet après-midi par l'audition
de Monsieur Hervé falsani ancien cadre
informaticien de la banque
HSBC monsieur je vais commencer par un
usage qui doit en être un également
maintenant pour vous qui consiste dans
la preststation de serment alors
voulez-vous vous lever monsieur Monsieur
Hervé Falciani prêterz serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
veuillez lever la main droite et dire je
le jure je le jure je vous en remercie
euh je vous propose mes chers collègues
chers collègues rapporteurs que nous
passions directement puisque c'est
désormais un sujet que si nous ne le
maîtrisons pas totalement nous en
connaissant tout de même un certain
nombre de contours que le rapporteur é
boet passe immédiatement aux questions
ce qui nous donnera puisque nous avons
une audition qui se terminera d'environ
1 heure plus le temps du débat des
questions et des
échanges la parole est à vous monsieur
le rapporteur bien merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur fseni d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous avez été
hier auditionné je crois par l'Assemblée
nationale donc vous êtes très sollicité
et pour cause depuis de nombreux mois
voir des années depuis cette fameuse
affaire qu' l'on appelle HSBC les
fichiers à l'origine de la publication
desquel vous êtes et donc c'est ce qui
nous amène bien sûr à vous entendre dans
cette commission d'enquête donc vous
savez qu'elle qu'elle att trait très
particulièrement au rôle des des banques
et des acteurs financiers dans le
système de l'évasion fiscale sur lequel
nous avions déjà travaillé l'en dernier
à l'occasion d'une première commission
d'enquête mais le sujet est tellement
immense complexe voire infini que nous
creusons notre sillon sur le sujet en
vue bien sûr de formuler des
propositions puisque c'est le le rôle de
cette commission d'enquête le rôle des
parlementaires de au terme de ce travail
de d'enquête de formuler des
propositions concrètes qui peuvent
devenir des lois de la réglementation
pour essayer de sortir de cette
situation dont il est question
régulièrement dans les médias et je
pense qu'il faut s'en féliciter donc
voilà donc c'est à ce titre là que nous
allons vous vous entendre et dans un
premier temps peut-être une première
question pour poser un peu le planter un
peu le décord
de sur le sujet qui vous concerne donc
je voudis savoir dans quelles conditions
exactement vous avez été amené à
soupçonner que les fichiers les fichiers
HSBC pour faire simple auquel vous avez
eu accès et dans quelles conditions cet
accès vous a-t-il été proposé contenait
des preuve de transfert illicite voilà
la première question introductive si
vous voulez bien sur la quel j'aimerais
vous entendre merci bien merci à vous
déjà de me recevoir et de me donner
l'occasion de de
partager les les éléments qui qui
relèvent de de la préservation de nos
intérêts fondamentaux et ce qui m'a fait
avancer vers la justice et pour pour le
faire de façon consistante récupérer
récolter un ensemble de preuves à même
de de supporter ce que je comptais bien
dénoncer au au plus haut niveau donc que
ce qui m'a fait prendre cette cette
position ce qui m'a fait entreprendre
cette démarche fut le le fait de
constater que la banque et une des
premières banques mondiales qui avait
pour charge à l'origine de de protéger
les intérêts des des clients et aussi
ses engagements au niveau de la société
et donc des des
états avait en fait pour seul intention
de se soustraire à ces obligations et
d'être dans une logique de contournement
de ces obligations et de ses
responsabilités c'est-à-dire au lieu d'y
faire face s'assurer de ne
pouvoir comment dire il
y s'y retrouver s'y retrouver confronté
et et ça passait donc par effectivement
des manquement en terme de régulation en
terme de contrôle au niveau du cœur de
ce qu'est l'activité bancaire et
financière aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire au
niveau de la maîtrise de ces outils
informatiques donc comment ai-je pu
récolter ces preuves et bien je l'ai pu
le faire que par l'intermédiaire de
personnes qui elles-même avaient accès
aux preuves lorsque moi-même je n'en
étais pas autorisé puisque pour rappeler
simplement mon rôle au sein de l' chsbc
Pravet Bank
j'étais lorsque je l'ai quitté en charge
des technical analyses des analyses
techniques pour le département des
projets stratégiques donc des projets
qui avaient pour objectif de permettre à
cette banque de s'adapter d'évoluer et
de s'adapter à quoi à des
réglementations à des tentative de
réguler et aussi de permettre de
contrôler donc ces activités bancaires
et et ce que j'avais donc expérimenté ce
dont j'avais été témoin pendant des
années c'était que la banque au lieu de
faire évoluer son système vers des
systèmes plus performant plus rigoureux
et qui permettait un meilleur contrôle
des opérations bancaires qui se
déroulaient en son in et bien chercher à
pouvoir se soustraire au mieux à ses
responsabilités et on pourra on aura
l'occasion je pense lors de cette
audition de prendre des cas concrets qui
aujourd'hui sont ben de par le temps
aussi passé à notre
disposition quelle a été votre
motivation fondamentale vous
évoquez nos intérêts fondamentaux ce
qu'on peut partager mais est-ce que vous
pourriez préciser détailler ce que vous
entendez exactement par là et qu'est-ce
qui a fait qu'un jour bon d'abord
préalablement quelles étaient vos
fonctions exactes au sein de la banque
en gros quel a été votre déroulement de
carrière dans cet établissement bancaire
et qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un jour vous
ayez décidé de d'avoir l'attitude que
vous avez aujourd'hui que je veux saluer
à titre personnel mais voilà quel a été
le l'élément de bascule à un moment
donné dans votre
réflexion qui dont don pour ne citer que
que mon père qui a travaillé dans la
Banque Privée
je suis né moi-même à Monaco et la
culture et la connaissance que j'avais
donc de l'activité la banque privée à
l'époque était plutôt associé à quoi à
la préservation des biens des propriétés
des des personnes de personnes qui
étaient dans des situations assez
particulières qui était souvent entre
plusieurs pays pour des raisons de
professionnelles qui
étit dans la nécessité de quitter leur
pays pour des raisons par exemple de
guerre civile et qui donc se retrouvai
ou qui en tout cas mettaient leur bien
en en sécurité dans des endroits comme
Monaco et ça c'est l'expérience que j'ai
eu euh petit enfant et puis grandissant
quand je rejoins l' chsbc en l'an 2000
c'est avec une mission qui est de
constituer un service de recherche et
développement local pour l'hsbc Monaco
et dans ce cadre-là euh il s'agit donc
de le doter de nouveaux outils
informatiques qui vont permettre un
meilleur contrôle des opérations
bancaires donc ce que je vois moi être
dans la continuité de cette logique
Bancaire Privée la banque privée qui est
de protéger les biens de clients et en
même temps d'assurer aussi de participer
à quoi à la traçabilité aussi bien donc
de de ces de ces biens et de leur
provenance cel cela dit le problème
surgira lorsque au lieu de cela je me
retrouverai dans une situation où la
volonté sera de faire évoluer vers des
systèmes qui seront qui se révéront
moins performants regard de
problématique de de de sécurité de de de
rigueur et on me fera donc partager
participer à des projets qui au lieu
donc de permettre un meilleur contrôle
et une meilleure protection des intérêts
même du client et des du respect des
engagements de la banque iront dans des
directions diamétralement opposées qui
permettront il y a y a des cas assez
emblématique par exemple de détecter si
des gestionnaires à un moment donné
présent un risque réputationnel pour la
banque ne peuvent pas être détectés
comme tel et invité à quitter la banque
avant même que la réputation de cette d
banque soit mise à mal donc vous voyez
on rentrit dans des outils de d'analyse
de connaissance et de de suivi des
opération bancaire qui avait pour
objectif en fin de compte de dédoiner la
banque de lui éviter d'être exposé
plutôt que d'aider à contrôler et à agir
comme aussi euh acteur
responsable de de la de la place
financière pour un rôle qui est quand
même central sur bien des points et je
parle de la rôle du rôle de la Banque
privé qui est un peu le le comment dire
le le gras de la finance là où où les
biens où une majorité par exemple de la
dette souveraine va se retrouver alors
excusez-moi d'y revenir monsieur falseni
mais quel est l'élément déclencheur dans
votre comportement à un moment donné
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous avez
décidé un jour ben de d'exploiter ces
fichiers donc sur Monaco en 2000 dès
qu'on rentre je on met en place un
projet qui permet déjà de révéler des
malversations d'un gestionnaire au
détriment des clients sur Monaco c'est
le le cas Steven Thot par la suite donc
ça va me permettre de participer à des
projets d'envergure européenne ça veut
dire au niveau de la direction sur
Genève et on me fait participer à un
projet qui s'appelle EDMS pour gestion
électronique des documents donc un
projet un système qui est censé garder
les documents une version numérique des
documents qui sont utiliser tous les
jours dans la banque sauf que on me
demande et on nous demande donc avec les
personnes qui sont en charge de ce
projet de faire de substituer un projet
à un système qui est fiable qui est
efficace qui permet d'éviter justement
qu'on qu'on le modifie qu'on modifie les
informations qu'il contient on demande
d'avancer d'évoluer vers un système qui
va lui permettre permettre qu'on puisse
modifier les documents qu'il contient
même puisque non plus enregistré sur des
supports euh inaltérables comme des
discoptiques ce qui était le cas pour le
précédent système mais vers des supports
qui sont eux tout à fait modifiable
effaçable et ça c'est la première
occasion de la prise de conscience que
on est vraiment on rentrait vraiment
dans une autre are où on pouvait effacer
et où on avait la possibilité donc euh
de d'agir sur quoi sur les traces de ce
que représente et de ce qui est attesté
du patrimoine d'un client c'est c'est ce
que vous entendez par malversation
exactement c'est-àdire que à ce moment
où je me réalise que au lieu de
fiabiliser un système euh qui permettra
d'assurer encore plus euh
professionnellement les euh les devoirs
de la banque euh vis-à-vis de ses
clients et vis-à-vis des états par la
suite c'est ça aussi que je vais voir et
bien je me rends compte que déjà là il y
a un problème il y a une un décalage
entre l'action et l'intention affiché et
une des premières actions sera interne
ça veut dire que en est avant d'être
lanceur d'alerte il se s'agit de se
comporter en tant que témoin et j'ai
essayé de l'intérieur de œuvrer malgré
tout pour rétablir la barre pour
redresser la barre et il va en résulter
quoi ben dans le casadre de ce projet
déjà on va obtenir qu'avec la
participation des des consultants
extérieur IBM de la compagnie IBM donc
qui a partagé l'effort de ce projet ont
puisse
aniser un dossier un rapport de de de
fin de de projet qui attestait des
manquements et des risques sécuritaire
auquel exposit donc la le remplacement
d'un ancien système par ce nouveau et
c'est ainsi que je vais continuer donc
ma progression au sein de la banque au
début donc comme simple analyse
technique pour un projet donné et pour
finir avec une vision plus transversal
plus plus global de l'ensemble des
systèmes
lorsque ultimement on on m'attribue donc
ce ce rôle de head of technical analyst
et pour donner un peu donc la la
continuité pour restituer la continuité
de de ma démarche interne et externe la
dernière une des dernières action que
j'ai eu à mener au sein de la banque
pour essayer aussi de de la ramener dans
des voies plus saines et bien ça aura
été d'organiser un colloc sur la
sécurisation des systèmes de passage
d'ordre et ça ce fut l'occasion de
réunir et de sensibiliser en tout cas
d'exprimer les problématiques à des
intervenants donc de la banque qui se
trouvaient aussi bien en Chine qu'en
Inde et avec donc le soutien aussi donc
de
d'autres architectes logiciels en
l'occurrence des personnes qui étaient
en Irlande mais pour dire que jusqu'à la
fin ayant malgré tout à un moment donné
réaliser que je ne pourrais rien faire
de proban depuis l'intérieur même de la
banque et qu'il a qu'il fallait et et
qu'il fallut donc se se référer à
d'autres autorités donc même malgré cela
même malgré ces deux voies euh d'alerte
et bien dans la banque j'ai continué
jusqu'à la fin à essayer aussi donc
d'alerter les personnes qui étit en
charge qui avait la responsabilité de
faire en sorte que le système soit
fiable et permettre de lutter et non pas
euh de laisser faire euh toutes toutes
sortes d'agissement on verra euh
l'histoire nous nous nous le montre on
verra que et c'est intéressant de de le
rappeler euh on a été témoin ces
derniers mois euh de ces de ces manques
des conséquences de ces manquements au
niveau de la régulation même de l'outil
informatique euh et je me réfère à quoi
à des systèmes à des des problématiques
comme les frères Malé vous avez
peut-être à l'esprit ces histoires
justement de blanchiment d'argent de la
drogue qui ont mis en cause cette banque
aussi mais là encore quand comme quand
au début donc de mon interlocution je je
vous expliquais l'attitude de la banque
qui consiste à éviter à contourner sa
responsabilité et là encore qu'a fait la
banque elle aura fermé le
département dans lequel officier donc
les personnes incriminées elle aura
demandé aux clients de clôturer leur
compte au lieu de quoi au lieu de
chercher à savoir si dans ses clients
certains clients étaient indésirables
étaient répréhensies et si dans les
employés certains étai compli donc là
encore on verra que au lieu d'aider à la
lutte à l'efficacité financière à la
probité
et à la légalité de ces opérations
financières la banque va rentrer dans
une démarche
d'évitement et quand personnellement
donc moi successivement je je suis
témoin du fait que d'un système robuste
on cherchera à passer un système
permissible et bien à chaque fois ce
sera une occasion pour m'inciter à
prendre des risques puisque n'ayant pas
un soutien
institutionnel sur en tant que lanceur
d'alerte je vais prendre des risques
pour amener pour constituer déjà les
preuves pour une justice et amener une
justice à s'intéresser à ce qui se
passait dans cette banque
donc première étape je commence à
essayer donc de de de solliciter
l'intervention des autorités françaises
suisses pardon cela ne se faisant pas la
prochaine qui rentrera en lit sera celle
française et ça sera par simplement euh
par un téléphone un appel à la Brigance
de lutte contre de la police judiciaire
contre la haute délinquance financière
qui elle va en fait me mettre dans les
mains de l'administration fiscale mais
ma première démarche et c'est l'occasion
aussi de le répéter fut orienté vers la
justice et la justice suisse puis
d'autres justices dont celle française
évidemment de suite après celle
Suisse après il y aurait différents
éléments qui qui serait intéressé de de
de partager le fait que ne serait-ce que
pour avoir donc
aujourd'hui dans les mains de la justice
française et d'autres justices ces
événements de preuve il a fallu avoir le
soutien de d'organism de de
renseignement de service de
renseignement qui ont permis d'amener
leur soutien logistique à à ce que on
sécurise ces informations pour qu'on
puisse les transmettre parce que il ne
faut pas oublier et là je reviens encore
là-dessus que mon rôle ne me donnait pas
accès aux informations sensies que ces
informations sensibles ont été
sécurisées et délivrées dans les mains
de la justice exclusivement hein pas
dans des médias ou des systèmes de
diffusion de l'information comme
Wikileak donc ont été délivrés dans les
mains de la justice grâce à une
infrastructure grâce à un support
logistique qui a été fourni donc par
certains
acteurs des services secrets de
renseignement et là aussi il faut
comprendre que dans tout ce qui est de
du domaine de la transparence dans tout
ce qui est du domaine de la lutte contre
l'opacité il n'y a pas d'alternative au
renseignement il n'y a pas d'alternative
au fait de connaître quelle est la
nature de la menace à laquelle nous
sommes exposés
donc peut-être que effectivement on
arrive à une limite en terme
diplomatique mais il faut comprendre que
normalement entre alliés qu'on se que
que l'on s'observe mutuellement ça peut
être pour les meilleures raisons du
monde donc il faut acter et je pense que
il faut aussi prendre l'occasion de de
mon expérience et mon retour
d'expérience pour acter que les
renseignements sont utiles et que ce
sont surtout des personnes mal
intentionnées qui auront intérêt à ce
que n' nit pas de transparence et pour
peu que bien sûr ça ne soit pas il
s'agisse pas comme je vous le dis hein
comme je l'ai fait moi je je ferait bien
la la la différence entre l'étalage
public et l'accès et la transparence aux
informations utiles pourquoi pour la
préservation de notre intérêt
général vous dites monsieur que vous
n'aviez pas accès forcément vous
directement personnellement à certaines
informations et en particulier à
certains ordinateurs enfin certaines
informations contenues informatiquement
et les services secrets certes mais pour
autant il faut bien qu'entre il y ait
des personnes qui fournissent ces
renseignements alors ma question est
assez simple est-ce que vous avez
actuellement des contacts personnels
avec des personnes qui peuvent vous
fournir des informations mais qui n'ont
pas encore accepté officiellement de
prendre comment dirais-je la cap du
lanceur
d'alerte il a il y a évidemment j'ai
évidemment évidemment en tête
différentes personnes qui qui seraiamè
d'amener un témoignage d'amener des
éclaircissements sur bien des points qui
méritent de l'êre
éclairci la problématique n'est pas tant
leur existence et vraiment comment et
vraiment comment leur permettre et et
permettre à ce que Ben d'autres aussi
que je ne connaîtrai pas puissent le
faire c'estd mais actuellement vous avez
des contacts avec ces gens-là je
continue effectivement avoir des
contacts sur sur comment évolue le
système et puis même par intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire en ayant aussi travaillé
dans avec d'autres d'autres justices
dans d'autres
structures d'autres pays seront équipés
de de de mécanismes de
renseignement de système de
renseignement qui vous permetttront de
garder malgré tout une une vision assez
à jour de ce qui se passe donc de
l'autre côté du mur de l'autre côté de
certains de certaines frontières là je
parlais du mur du secret
bancaire mais mais bref
oui j'ai quand même effectivement encore
un certain nombre d'informations qui me
reviennent
oui monsieur fa j'ai pas très bien
compris les les raisons qui vous ont
conduit à avoir des soupçons clairs sur
les les données des fameux Fichi HSBC
est-ce que vous pourriez y revenir s'il
vous plaît parce que vous avez suggéré
n'avoir pas accès navoir pas eu accès
aux données mais que celle-ci avait été
extraite grâce au service de
renseignement c'est ce que vous venez de
dire à l'instant vous pourz clarifier ce
point s'il vous plaît bien sûr en fait
ce que j'ai j'ai j'ai essayé de de
partager avec vous c'est simplement que
au niveau de de l'accès à ces
informations à ces éléments de preuve
j'ai eu l'aide d'autres personnes au
sein de la banque par contre pour
assurer assurer le fait que personne n
en sa possession ces éléments de preuve
personne d'autre que des justices déjà
et bien il a fallu recourir à un certain
nombre d'expertises en terme de
sécurisation et de transport de ces
informations puisque
bon il faut bien il faut bien comprendre
que il y a une différence entre
l'obtention et la mise à disposition et
c'est dans la mise à disposition qu'il a
fallu qu'on
m'aide je parle là en l'occurrence des
services de renseignement par contre
pour ce qui est de l'obtention pas à ma
connaissance ils nont pas ils ne sont
pas intervenus à ce niveau-là ma
connaissance puisque ils sont intervenus
dans cette mise à disposition aussi
suite à ma
demande c'est-à-dire que quand moi je me
trouve face à une situation inextricable
ù je ne veux je ne vois vraiment pas
comment je vais réussir premièrement à
sécuriser ces informations et à les
faire parvenir dans dans les mains
souhaité et bien je j'alerte les
personnes les compétences d'État qui me
semble la même de m'aider dans ma
démarche et ça passera donc par la
sollicitation d'un certain nombre de
service de renseignement ce qui fait
qu'encore aujourd'hui malgré euh la la
présentation
malgré le nom sur lesquel C ces ces
personnes se sont présentées à moi et
ont aidé concrètement factuellement je
n'aurais jamais en tout cas je je n'ai
pas aujourd'hui l'assurance de leur
réelle identité déclarée ce que je sais
c'est que leur action a été euh positive
et a permis dans dans les cadres qu'on
s'était donnés bah d'aboutir à ce que la
justice aujourd'hui est ses preuv
vous voulez vous voulez dire que les
documents enfin les pièces que vous avez
obtenu vous les avez obtenu anonymement
c'est-à-dire que vous ne mettez pas un
nom sur la personne qui vous a fait qui
vous a transmis une information ou un
ou cl USB que sais-je non non non pas du
tout non les informations moi j'ai eu
j'ai eu deux rôles j'ai eu premièrement
donc un rôle pour assurer l'acheminement
dans les mains de la justice de ces
informations et deuxièmement j'ai eu le
rôle d'assurer que ces information soit
consistante c'estàdire elles m'ont été
donné par des personnes que je
connaissais et les ayant obtenu j'ai dû
m'assurer de leur
intégrité et cela fait je les ai mis
après j'ai j'ai j'ai je dirais j'ai
profité de de l'assistance amenée par
justement un service de renseignement
pour pouvoir les mettre à disposition
oui avant de passer parole à notre
collègue Marie no l est-ce que vous avez
pris le temps de d'analyser ces fichiers
vous-même avant de vous en saisir et
qu'est-ce que vous avez pu observer à
l'occasion de cette analyse que vous
avez éventuellement faite euh elles ont
certainement été partielles étant donné
l'ampleur des données qui sont assez
assez conséquentes qu'est-ce qui a
retenu votre attention à l'examen de ces
données des noms des montants d' cours
par exemple euh en aucun cas en aucun
cas je me suis intéressé si on peut dire
aux
particularités aux instances d'opération
bancairire et encore moins ou non par
contre euh quand vous parlez de
partialité non ceux qui on s'est fait
fort de récupérer c'est l'intégralité
donc l'intégralité à la fois de quoi de
certains systèmes qui montrai quoi qui
montrait justement la permissivité de la
banque et ses agissements et euh et dans
ce cadre donc c'est simplement parce que
euh et bien pour que ces systèmes
fonctionnent euh il devait contenir des
listes de clients qu'on pouvait
retrouver des liste de clients mais mon
principal intérêt à l'origine était de
restituer les éléments explicatifs de
comment fonctionne la banque et de façon
la plus factuelle la plus comment dire
inattaquable possible en restituant en
l'état dans lequel se trouvaient ces
informations au sein même de la banque
ça veut dire sans constituer par exemple
des listes telles que ce fut fait par
des administrations qui avaient des
mandats et qu' on eu des mandats précis
et et limités limités à des listes déjà
donc moi en aucun cas je me suis
intéressé à des lis mais je me suis
intéressé à l'intégrité de système et
les éléments qui représentai le
fonctionnement de ces systèmes et à la
mise à disposition donc de ces
éléments je vais donner la parole à
Madame minman notre collègue qui veut
vous poser une question oui monsieur euh
deux questions la première c'est que
vous indiquez que vous avez donc
bénéficié du soutien des services de
servicees de renseignement pour faire
passer si je peux dire les informations
à un stade opérationnel pour la justice
euh je voudrais vous demander on avait
entendu à l'époque un ministre des
Finances nous indiquer qu'il avait une
liste de noms mais que cette liste ne
pouvait pas être utilisée parce qu'elle
avait été entre guillemets volée et
n'avait pas été légal
transmise à la justice est-ce que vous
avez connaissance des mécanismes de
transmission est-ce que de votre point
de vue ils avaient été illégalement
transmis c'est le premier point et la
deuxième chose puisque il y a des
services de renseignement donc quelle
est la nature de ces services de
renseignement en terme de d'efficacité
juridique de de ce passage hein la
deuxième chose c'est que vous avez parlé
des projets stratégiques vous dites que
dans l'organisation de la banque il y
avait des système de compétenence de la
banque qui était mis au service de
projets stratégiquees or nous nous
réfléchissons à la manière dont les
états la puissance publique peut
organiser sa riposte devant l'évasion
fiscale qui est un mécanisme qui
s'adapte très vite comme un virus mutant
quoi hein et donc est-ce que de votre
point de vue il y aurait pas nécessité
d'une sorte de de similitude
d'organisation c'est-à-dire d'avoir des
task forces des qui travaillent sur des
projets stratégiques de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale et pouvez-vous nous
dire ce qu'il en est de de ces projets
stratégique qui ça réunissait dans les
banques quelles compétences était mises
en œuvre pour voir si éventuellement par
symétrie il serait pas utile de croiser
les compétences au sein de l'État oui
bien volontiers je répondre à vos
questions euh donc pour la première euh
lorsqu'il s'agit justement de de la des
procédures fiscales et
judiciaire toutes les informations et
quand quand j'ai parlé du rôle de de
certains services de
renseignement donc il il a permis quoi
il a permis le fait un fa unique dans
l'histoire que des informations soi
transmises à la justice française par la
justice
suisse c'est-à-dire toutes les
informations dont on va discuter et dont
on a entendu parler pendant des années
ont été mis à disposition par à la suite
d'une d'entraite judiciaire Suisse donc
c'est de par les demandes de saisie de
scellé et les résultats donc de ces
saisies donc les Cellé de cette
commission rogatoire internationale
Suisse a permis à la France et à la
justice française de récupérer ces
informations ce qui veut dire qu'il n'y
aura jamais eu plus euh direct et plus
naturel
euh transmission de données que dans ce
cadre-là que dans le cas dans ce cas
unique donc de ce qu'on appellera
sûrement l'affaire HSBC
quand un
ministre
prétend parle de données volé il ne peut
s'agir il peut s'agir que d'une
manipulation qu'une entrave pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui encore aucun
jugement n'a été
prononcé sur quoi que ce soit dans cette
affaire donc encore moins de vol de
données donc quand un représentant euh
de l'autorité quand quand un élu quand
quelqu'un qui qui qui devrait soutenir
les lois prétend cela et bien c'est du
domaine de l'entrave c'est du domaine de
la manipulation et contre nos intérêts
propre ça c'est mon point de vue de de
citoyen euh de témoin de ce que j'ai
vécu parce que il y aura d'autres
épisodes euh qui s'affaireront à cette à
cette à cet événement là hein de
déclaration comme quoi des données ont
été
volées et ces autres interventions
auront été par exemple le fait de
brandir une liste ce qui aurait pu être
très bien fait un an plus tard laissant
le temps aux institutions judiciaire de
progresser d'enquêter tranquillement
sans qu'on alerte les personnes qui
risquaient une enquête et bon après on
pourrait continuuer dans le sens mais il
y a une autre question là pour les
autions il aura eu de nombreuses il en
aura eu au ple niveau il y aura eu des
demandes de druction de Cellé en les
retournant à la Suisse il aura été
demandé d'accord que non seulement une
copie des cell soit communiqué à la
Suisse mais carrément que l'on retourne
les cell à la Suisse ce quientr entraîné
quoi judiciaairement une destruction de
preuve de preuve pour donc quoi pour des
preuves qui aujourd'hui historiquement
sont une des un des premiers cas dans
dans dans notre histoire donc de la
lutte contre l'OPAC financière et et et
l'évasion fiscale et Ben sont uniques
donc moi je je je conclurai là pour
cette première
question sur justement lorsqu'on a parlé
et et mystifier donc le public et bien
d'autres jusqu'à justement des
magistrats sur la notion de de donné
volé et puis je jeeviendrai donc sur la
deuxième question qui est
justement comment faire face à à cette
menace
alors chaque fois qu'on a une menace on
pense en terme de défense donc la
défense nationale
juste quelques jours après donc le 14
juillet il est important de de de de de
de faire le rapprochement entre les
différents types de menaces auxquelles
nous sommes exposés dans le cadre de la
menace donc de l'opacité financière de
la
dérégulation de de l'absence de contrôle
de ces opérations puisque comme je vous
le le le disait en début de séance et
bien nous avons des des personnes qui au
lieu de prendre des responsabilités et
partir et participer à la lutte
contre justement la la délinquence
financière ils feront ils prendront soin
de d'éviter toute exposition à ces
risques simplement et bien on verra que
donc on on manque on manque d'autorités
qui se substitueront et qui rempliront
ce rôle qui se substitueront à C les
acteurs financiers et qui rempliront ce
rôle donc dans la banque on aura des
systèmes d'adaptation on peut essayer
c'est un axe extrêmement important
effectivement de
reproduire des systèmes qui vont ben
offrir des des vaccins qui s'adapteront
au fur à mesure que ce virus se mutera
et donc pour se faire et bien reprendre
la même dynamique d'adaptation de nos
défenses tout comme il y a des mécanis
des mécanismes d'adaptation de on va
dire ces virus si si vous comprenez on
comprendra bien de de quoi je parle
alors effectivement ça passera par quoi
par constituer des équipes l'équivalent
sûrement d'un département projet
stratégique quelque chose qui se
rapprochera de ce que l'on aura en
Espagne euh sous le nom rassemblé sous
le nom dequ de de parquet antiorruption
où on aura un ensemble de compétences
c'estàdire que à l'identique que dans le
département stratégique où on avait un
ensemble de compétences réuni et bien à
nous aussi de constituer ce ce genre de
d'entité pour bah justement d'un côté
pouvoir récupérer les informations sur
les les menaces auxquelles nous sommes
exposés de l'autre analyser ces menaces
donc vous voyez bien il y a la
connaissance métier ce sera dans la
banque un département qui est dédié à la
connaissance du métier et des
opportunités
euh proposé à la banque et et la la
plupart du temps une opportunité c'est
quoi c'est une évolution
réglementaire donc ce lorsque nous ici
nous cherchons à entraver un
comportement qui nous
est pénalisant et bien la banque elle va
prendre cela comme une opportunité une
opportunité pour prendre un service
d'évitement pour proposer un service
d'évitement et pour proposer service
donc le projet stratégique va faire quoi
et bien va étudier quelles sont les
modifications en son 5 qu'il doiv être
opéré et va donc mener à son terme ces
modifications et donc nous on pourrait
effectivement connaissant prenant
connaissance de comment la banque va
s'organiser pour faire face à une
réglementation et bien évaluer euh un
plan d'action qui aura pour but bah de
contrecarrer cette cette cette cette
offre de service nouveau avenir qui
par les les les structures en en en
présence
vient souvent avant même la la date de
mise en application de ces
réglementations oui avec la permission
de mon collègue Jacques Chiron qui a une
question à poser vous voulez dire que
des des fichiers ont été transmis dans
dans le cadre d'une commission rogatoire
certes mais par qui a-t-elle été
formulée d'abord et d'après ce qu'on
sait c'est la justice suisse qui qui a
fait cette demande donc dans comment ça
s'est passé en détail donc moi une fois
sur
France je me je me fais fort donc de
récupérer les informations une fois sur
FR je ne suis pas sorti de Suisse avec
des informations avec les preuves que je
comptais donner à la justice française
mais je les ai récupérer sur France ces
preuves et les aant chez moi lorsque la
commission régatoire s'exécute et bien
sont saisis à mon domicile ces
informations que j'avais donc récupéré
et validé à nouveau donc ces ces cellés
sont effectués par la gendarmerie
nationale sont transmises donc
directement au parquet par les services
secrets ou non non directement par
l'action de la série par l'exécution de
la commission rogatoire internationale
demandée par la Suisse donc c'est dans
sous la la demande c'est sous oui sous
sous la la tutelle de la Suisse que ces
informations sontéc transmise à la
justice française et comment
dire finissent atterrissent dans les
mains de la justice française et c'est
là où moi je vais alerter le procureur
monsieur Éric de montolfier sur
l'intérêt pour la préservation de de de
nos de nos intérêts fondamentaux qu'il
fallait qu'il qu'il s'intéresse à ces
informations et non pas qu'il les
retransmettent sans rien faire à la
Suisse comme celle-ci le demandait et
donc c'est c'est aussi essentiellement
par son action que ces preuves là
finiront dans les mains de la justice
française notre collègue chir va vous
poser une
question le système
d'vitement de la part de la banque céta
sur des actes considérés comme criminel
àch international c'estàd que ils ont
voulu cacher d'près ce que j'ai compris
un certain nombre de comptes relevant
d'actes criminel à l'ch
international donc ça signifie pour
éviter de les déclarer je pour éviter de
le déclarer ou pas si vous voulez c'est
malheureusement c'est plus c'est plus
étendu la problématique elle est plus
étendue que qu'au qu'au simple cas de
cette banque qui est déjà emblématique
de par sa
taille si vous permettez je va je vais
je vais reformuler pour être bien sûr de
m'êre bien
exprimé vous avez un système financier
qui est un peu constitué comme un œuf
vous avez une coquille et vous avez
dedans une matière molle dans laquelle
on pourrait se déplacer une fois passer
la coquille et une une coquille qui est
assez faible d'accord donc la coquille
c'est là où se concentre la
responsabilité au regard par exemple des
institutions judiciaires suisses et que
qui qui constitue cette coquille ce sont
les gestionnaires de fortune au niveau
de la banque ce qui veut dire que
imaginez-vous vous avez
donc une entité le système financier qui
repose pour lesquels la responsabilité
de ce qui se déroule repose sur la tête
de quelques individus officiellement
donc ça veut dire que la banque elle va
se permettre d'offrir tous les services
que vont demander ses gestionnaires pour
des raisons commerciales et par contre
si le gestionnaire fait pas ce qu'il ce
qu'il ce qu'il devrait ce sera lui qui
sera responsable au niveau de la loi or
comment lui instituer sa responsabilité
si on n'est pas à même de déceler son
activité et c'est toute la problématique
de la banque dire que si il n'y a pas un
contrôle de cette Mar partie molle qui
représente l'essentiel de la finance et
bien on ne pourra jamais ou très
difficilement restituer la
responsabilité à la coquille au niveau
de la coquille au niveau des
intermédiaires au niveau des
gestionnaires et et c'est simplement et
c'est c'est toute la la subtilité de de
la démarche c'est que en rendant de plus
en plus fine cette coqu
en l'éloignant de plus en plus de de ce
qui est la banque donc de l'œuf de de la
matière molle de l'œuf et bien la banque
participe aide à ce que Ben nous nous
soyons démunis face à des comportements
délictueux et je vous ai cité les
exemples des frères ELM en France les
exemples j'aurais pu vous prendre aussi
l'exemple par exemple du d'un chef de la
mafia chinoise en Espagne
gauping qui utiliser quoi la même banque
cette même banque HSBC Genève et dans
les deux cas pour du blanchiment et dans
les deux cas dans des cadres qui
mettront qui exposeront en terme
judiciaire qui simplement les
intermédiaires simplement les
intermédiaires et la banque elle
réussira toujours à se maintenir hors de
toute poursuite jusqu'ici parce que les
réglementations sont faites t tel
qu'ell et et c'est bien ça la la
difficulté c'est que ce ne sont pas avec
des réglementations qu'on va pouvoir
interférer avec ces mécanismes avec ses
comportements ce seront bien avec des
actitudes et avec des actions dynamiques
ça sera bien par exemple en se
rapprochant des intermédiaires financier
quand l'Amérique demande à la
Suisse
l'échange automatique des des noms des
clients la Suisse bon gré malgré va
accepter va rochigner va présenté comme
bon si c'était très grave mais va
accepter parce que le temps que ça passe
en vigueur elle aura déjà trouvé un
mécanisme d'évitement par contre quand
on lui demande à la Suisse de
communiquer ses
intermédiaires ses
avocats toute personne qui aura un rôle
déterminant dans dans ses activités
financières et bien là il y aura une
levée de bouclier généralisée alors là
on on arrivera à la
limite de la coopération et et c'est
tout le point c'est que c'est tout est
dans la subtilité on est pas dans du
gros œuvres on est vraiment dans de
l'orphèverie et et dans ces PL et dans
ce travail là dans ce domaine là il y a
des places qui qui concentrent ses
compétences et qui nous obligent nous
qui nous oblige nous donc à acquérir ces
mêmes compétences pour pouvoir rivaliser
et donc à reconstituer un environnement
qui permettra à ces compétences de se
développer et d'être au même niveau que
celle et bien de de nos
opposants
très bien
oui personnellement je vouis poser une
autre question dans au début lorsque on
évoque un nombre de comptes révélés par
vos informations on évoque un nombre
x par la suite
euh interrogeant les différentes
personnes qui ont pu accéder à ces
comptes qui ont pu les vérifier qui ont
pu les contrôler on nous indique que
certains sont des doublons que certains
sont des comptes déclarés Epsilon
quelques-uns et que certains ont des
états nuls enfin sont des comptes soldés
et ont finit par aboutir à X divisé par
4 ou divisé par 5 pour vous c'est
crédible alors déjà
euh je ne remettrai jamais en cause le
travail de l'administration parce que
j'ai vu avec quel moyens ils avait à
œuvrer et et le vrai et la vraie
responsabilité euh réside dans le fait
de ne pas lui avoir donné jusqu'ici les
moyens maintenant pour prendre pour
revenir au chiffres il faut voir que
nous sommes dans une situation complexe
et comme on le comprend bien si on n pas
une connaissance perfa perfaite parfaite
pardon de de ces mécanismes on ne pourra
pas ayant les preuves devant les yeux on
ne pourra pas les exploiter ça veut dire
que si je viens et c'est ce que j'ai
vécu d'ailleurs quand je me suis
retrouvé face à une qutité astronomique
d'information à partager avec par
exemple l'administration fiscale ces
messieurs étaient bien démuni face à ça
il ne pouvait pas l'exploiter on a
travaillé pendant des mois pour
exploiter une partie une simple une
partie la la plus intéressante par
rapport à leur mandat
exclusif sur quelques mois on a pu
exploiter ces quelques information mais
tout le reste qui était juste adossé à
ce qu'on avait exploité faute de pouvoir
expliquer de quoi ils st ils sen retourn
ils n'ont pas pu les exploiter et des
éléments aussi importants que les
intermédiaires financiers dont on vient
de parler ne sachant pas qu'il qu'ils
étaient représentés sous tel format dans
ces informations ils n'était pas même
pour les exploiter donc quand on parle
de liste il faut comprendre qu'on parle
d'extraction ça veut dire c'est comme
une prise de sang dans un organisme on
aura une vue ciblée choisie d'un
organisme ça sera par exemple son ça sa
glycémie donc quand on va voir par
exemple quand on va faire une prise de
sang qui correspond à une liste une
liste de de comptes on aura quoi comme
doublon alors reprenant les chiffres on
aura plusieurs centaines de milliers de
comptes compes bancairirees sachant
qu'une personne pouvant détenir
plusieurs comptes donc on peut très bien
avoir une liste où on aura pour sur
plusieurs lignes le même même nom mais
avec un compte différent donc ça ça
constituera un doublon en terme de
personne mais pas un doublon en terme
d'information on aura plusieurs comptes
pour une même personne ensuite quand il
s'agit d'établir par exemple un
patrimoine pour une personne si on
connaît pas les les les les biens les
les les produits financiers qui sont
disponibles pour les clients et bien on
va se retrouver dans des situations qui
sont assez inattendues pour pour les
personnes justement qui qui ne les
connaissent pas je vais vous prendre
l'exemple des dépôts
fiduciaires le dépôt de fiduciaire
correspond consiste à déléguer la
propriété d'un bien un peu comme pour
les trusts sauf que là c'est un dépôt
vous avez un million vous donnez vous
vous déléguez vous transmettez cette la
propriété de ce million pendant pendant
6 mois donc pendant 6 mois ce bien c'est
un peu comme pour certaines formes
d'assurance vie ben ce bien va être à la
propri qui était de la banque donc si
vous on regarde l'état de vos biens vous
vous avez zéro vous avez - 1000 Mo 1
million Mo- 100 millions donc si vous il
vous reste par exemple dans sur une si
vous
lisez une une liste dans lequelle
apparaîtra d'un côté en
positif 5 million et de l'autre moin 1
million votre premier réflexe ça sera de
soustraire et d'obtenir 4 millions sauf
que ce moins million correspond à la
trace dans le système du fait que vous
détenez 5 millions et non pas TR oui
comment comment un client de la banque
pe simplement excusez-moi pour arriver à
la conclusion de de ce que je je
comptais partager avec
vous rien que la le patrimoine d'un
client n'est pas quelque chose
d'intuitif n'est pas quelque chose qui
pourra
faute de connaître vraiment la banque
qui pourra être établie par une simple
disposition disponibilité
d'information donc si vous détenez les
informations bancaires si vous n'êtes
pas à même de bien les interpréter vous
allez arriver à des décalages très
conséquents comment un client d'une
banque entrant dans ce type de mécanisme
là peut-il se préserver contre
l'appréhension de ses propre fond pu
qu'on est dans l'occulte complet a
délégué la propriété
à une personne interposée comment
peut-il se prémunir de récupérer cet
argent et d'échapper à une propre
frautete de la banque à sans
détriment vous vous revenez
sur sur un apprentissage que j'ai eu
tout jeune encore une fois mon père
quand les premiers mots qui m'a qui m'a
transmis les premières prers oui élément
de compréhension de la banque qu'il m'a
transmis F la banque et la négation de
la confiance il faut viser et superviser
c'est un principe il y a des principes
comme ça comme le principe des quatre
yeux où on devrait assurer que chaque
opération soit visée supervisée donc
pour éviter justement que quelqu'un de
malintentionné puisse détourner des bien
et à une époque donc où l'époque où il
me transmettait ceses ces connaissances
on était dans l'époque où les les les
éléments étaient sur des cahiers sur des
registres où on ne pouvait pas effacer
on ne pouvait pas faire disparaître euh
comme l'informatique l'a permis depuis
et et c'est toute la difficulté
c'est-à-dire que quand on parle de
secret on va euh ben on va revenir à des
à des à des à des événements qu'on a
qu'on a connu sous le terme par exemple
des des fonds en desérance et si on voit
hein c'est pas simplement spécifique à à
la Suisse ou aux endroits où on aura un
secret bancaire très très très exigeant
mais déjà en France ça ça existe déjà en
France quand vous allez estimer les les
biens en déserrance en France et ben
vous pourrez par un ça sera même plus un
facteur multiplicatif mais sera plutôt
exponentiel vous pouvez imaginer ce
qu'il peut se produire derrière un mur
aussi au plus le mur sera sera solide
d'ailleurs vous pourrez imaginer donc
qu'est-ce qui pourra se passer derrière
un mur comme le mur du secret bancaire
suisse merci nous allons revenir aux
questions de notre rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président oui afin de bien
comprendre votre cheminement monsieur
fciani donc vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que vous avez quitté le territoire
suisse si j'ai bien compris sans être en
possession des des documents des
fichiers en question et dans ce cas-là
la question se pose de savoir qui vous a
aidé au transfert de de ces données
est-ce que ça est-ce que les services
secrets ont eu un rôle concret dans
cette opération là voilà ça c'est la
première question que je voulais vous
poser ensuite deuxème question dans
quelles conditions la justice suisse
vous êtes-elle identifié comme étant
possesseur de de ces fichiers et 3è
question pour cette série-là euh quels
ont été vos interlocuteurs au ministère
des Finances en France euh un témoin a
fait état de divers tractations dans les
services fiscaux ça a été repris dans la
presse à plusieurs reprises est-ce que
vous pourriez nous donner des précisions
sur leur
objet pour la dernière partie de pour la
dernière de vos questions je suis pas
très je suis pas tout à fait sûr d'avoir
bien compris quand vous parlez de de
tractation euh bon pour revenir donc et
prendre dans l'ordre vos questions oui
c'est en fait c'est le juge de monolfier
qu'on a auditionné l'an dernier qui
faisait état de ce sont ces propos que
nous reprenons dans dans l'audition et
voilà il a fait état de cette
situation moi je vais vous réituer ce
qu'il s'est passé hein aussi bien donc à
partir du moment où j'ai quitté la
Suisse et après lorsqu'il s'agit de de
de travailler donc avec comprise
l'administration fiscale donc lorsque je
quitte la Suisse effectivement
je n'ai pas d'information avec moi je
aucune information je rentre en France
sans rien et quand je vous ai parlé donc
du rôle de de certains services de
renseignement il s'agit sur la mise de
la sécurisation la mise en sécurité de
ces informations pour qu'elle puisse
être disponible aussi bien depuis la
France que depuis l'Espagne ou que
depuis de tout autrre pays sans que sans
courir le risque que par ma disparition
elle disparaissent
aussi donc c'est simplement ça c'estd
que et l'essentiel du rôle des services
de renseignement a été donc d'assurer
cela une partie aussi quand même bien
importante aura été dans les mécanismes
qui ont entraîné la Suisse à venir
percionner sur France qui cela aussi est
de leur et de leur tribu leur revient
c'est aussi grâce à eux qu'on a pu
organiser cette
judiciarisation dans un pays où les
réglementations nous imposent et nous
évitent de pouir vraiment V lutter
efficacement mais bon c'est un autre
débat c'est un autre sujet quand donc
une fois rentré et une fois ses donné
perquisitionné
donc disponible pour la justice
française une fois cela fait moi j'ai
simplement amené donc mes
éclaircissements sur la nature des
informations comme je l'ai expliqué les
informations telles qu'ell si je
vouslais donner et si je l'ai donné au
au aux personnes les plus expertes dans
dans dans la lutte au niveau français si
je l'ai donné demain il serait bien à
même euh d'établir qu'ils ne peuvent
rien en faire il ne sauraient pas quoi
en faire il pourrait retrouver peut-être
quelques noms et et et et en fait le le
le test se f fait ainsi quand moi je
leur ai transmis ces données je n'avais
pas de de connaissance particulière sur
leur niveau de compétence sur
l'exploitation sur leur capacité
d'exploiter ces données et ce sont eux
qui sont revenus vers moi pour me dire
écoute j'ai bien vu euh qu'il y avait
des noms par-ci par là mais
euh je suis incapable de pouvoir les les
les utiliser et c'est à ce moment que
j'ai commencé à travailler avec donc
tractaction correspondant à quoi comment
correspondant justement à un travail à
l'organisation d'un travail à des
réunions les les seuls éléments de de
tractation que je vois et que j'ai vécu
ont été afférentes au fait d'organiser
des séances de
travail le travail explicatif et
gracieusement évidemment he comme à
chaque fois donc tout au long de ces
années j'ai amené ma contribution aussi
bien au niveau de l'administration
fiscale que que de la justice française
et d're justice
gracieusement volontairement et en ayant
comme limite simplement le temps qu'on m
avait imparti pour le faire c'est-à-dire
que dans un ensemble d'obstructions dont
dont nous avons été victime he puisque
c'est nos intérêts qui qui qui
empathisent à terme et bien a été aussi
organisé le fait que je ne puiss pas de
façon
consistante apporter toute mon aide ne
serait-ce que dans l'explication des
mécanismes et dans le fait de mettre en
place une défense qui soit à la hauteur
de de de de de des menaces mais
aujourd'hui les choses sont sont d'une
autre nature les intentions sont
différentes et je je suis plus
qu'optimiste je suis certain qu'on qu'on
va réussir à à redresser la barre mais
monsieur précisément sur ce point vous
avez incontestablement une expertise
très précieuse d'abord vous êtes
ingénieur système en plus vous
connaissez le système bancaire qui
organise l'opacité donc vous avez une
expertise j'allais dire
monayable est-ce que l'État français
vous a proposé de vous rémunérer pour
que vous agissiez en qualité d'expert
pour analyser ces informations que vous
nous dites difficilement analysabl par
d'autres peut-être alors ma question est
est-ce que l'État français vous a
proposé de de de vous indemniser de vous
de de cette expertise voir est-ce que
vous l'êtes non non en aucun cas en
aucun cas jamais et puis j'ai j'ai
offert gracieusement mon mon aide depuis
le
début non dans dans que dans dans des
dans des oui que que dans des domaines
limités jusqu' iici aujourd'hui nous
sommes en train de de chercher une voie
une voie pour justement que je puisse
apporter mon aide
puisque pour que je puisse continuer
cette lutte ce qui qui est devenue un
engagement personnel mais comment vous
exp comment vous expliquez ça que vous
offrez là votre expertise vous amenez un
certain nombre de choses et à tous les
nouveaux vous nous indiquez il y a un
blocage on ne me permet même pas d'aider
d'apporter mon expérience comment vous
expliquez ça qui est ce on le on on ne
m'a pas aidé enfin oui dés est le ben je
vais vous dire si si on prend alors
prenons bah pour pour la partie la plus
emblématique prenons
donc le précédent président de la
République qui va prétendre que les
paradis fiscaux c'est sont finis C son
action concrète la seule dont moi je
puisse témoigner don nous pouvons tous
témoigner parce que malheureusement je
peux pas témoigner qu'il a aidé à quoi
que ce soit pour ma part bien son seule
action concrète aura été de permettre au
Panama de pouvoir continuer à travailler
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
prenons revenons aux
faits d'accord le précédent le
gouvernement de le précédent
gouvernement et son représentant et pour
être très précis et et concis je dirais
quand il a eu une action à à à mener
quand il a mené une action ça a été pour
rendre une place qui est euh tout à fait
connu pour ses dérives dans la gestion
des patrimoines immobiliers qui est le
Panama et donc la France qu'elle a eu
une action elle a été au niveau des
paradis fiscaux sous la présidence de
Monsieur Sarkozi a été néfaste pour nos
intérêts personnels pour tous nos
intérêts généraux donc je réponds aussi
à votre question alors c'est pas
détourné parce que je peux pas faire
état d'une aide qui a été apportée dans
cette lutte au regard de ma connaissance
des moyens de lutte dont on aurait
besoin et dont on a besoin mais je peux
vous faire état de ce qui a été fait et
qui va contre nos intérêts il est exact
que vous n'avez pas pu rencontrer
Monsieur
kusac lorsque vous vous avez également
voulu lui fournir des informations je
vous le confirme autant cette lutte
dépend dépasse les les partis politiques
puisque c'est c'est du domaine de
l'intérêt général et nous sommes tous
dans dans la même barque si je puis dire
autant il y a effectivement des
personnes qui auront eu un rôle clé et
et le pire dans la corruption ce n'est
pas de faire quelque chose contre même
si comme je vous disais il y a eu des
actions contre qui ont été menées non le
pire dans la corruption c'est de laisser
rien faire et de ne pas aider aid à ce
que soit fait parce que ce sont des
déterminations et ce sont des actions
concrètes franches qui qui nécessitent
un investissement un engagement qui
permettent de lutter contre une telle
menace quand vous savez qu'il s'agit de
par an et c'est une estimation à minima
de plusieurs dizaines de milliards quand
vous comprenez que l'enjeu est de cet
ordre et bien vous comprenez que ça
nécessiterait un pourcentage de cet
unjeu d'investissement et aujourd'hui
l'investissement est n'est n'est pas
fait même à minima donc euh c'est
l'intérêt aussi de de nos rencontres
c'est l'intérêt de comprendre que nous
avons la possibilité de faire mais que
simplement aujourd'hui euh et et je suis
heureux de voir
que que dans le gouvernement que dans
l'administration il y a un changement
qui qui se laisse qui se laisse sentir
qui est en voie d'arriver et qu'on va
peut-être donc grâce à cela euh si on le
maintient si on maintient C effort et si
on le mène à son terme on va enfin
pouvoir se dotter d'une défense qui soit
adaptée à la
menace est-ce que vous pourriez préciser
monsieur falsen les ce que vous entendez
par action contre d'une part et je
voudrais revenir un peu en arrière sur
les types d'opération des cas concrets
que vous aviez annoncé nous détailler
nous serions très preneur de quelques
exemples très concrets de ce type
d'opération dans dans cette activité
s'il vous plaît oui bien donc bon il y
en a de de toutes sortes hein si on
prend des des exemples par exemple sur
les régulations les réglementations
l'équivalent on a on a un exemple
aujourd'hui dans la lutte l'exemple
américain d'accord donc quand je vous
dis qui a été fait contre donc un des
acteurs phare dans dans la lutte contre
l'opacité financière et en tout cas
l'évasion fiscale a été jusqu'ici
l'Amérique donc les États-Unis
l'Amérique et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
d' ils ont chercher donc simplement à à
mettre la pression à à révéler à
expliquer les les mécanismes et à
obtenir des
information
quand ils ne pouvaient pas le faire
directement ils ont mis en place des
réglementations comme le qualified
intermediary le QI qui qui permettait
donc la taxation des ressortissants
américains sur la base de de la de
l'origine des des des des produits qu'il
détenait donc si c'était des produits
d'origine américaine et bien une partie
des bénéfices issus de laion ces
produits devaent être reversé et dans ce
cadre là la banque se comportter en
percepteur pour l'Amérique quand la
France quand l'Europe de façon plus
générale a cherché à faire la même chose
et ce qui est ce qui s'est trouvé appelé
par le SD European saving directive
qu'est-ce qui en est ressorti que la
réglementation s'occupait prévoyait de
de taxer les personnes physiques et non
pas les personnes morales donc donc la
faille ou plutôt la démarche le projet
stratégique à qui a
pris le biais de de cette évolution
règlementaire a été de identifier les
personnes
qui payeraient plus que la mise en place
d'une
structure légale derrière laquelle il
auraiit pu donc s'abriter qui qui aurait
pu payer plus que en bénéficiant de
certains produits bon j'en ai nommé j'en
ai nommé un dernièrement là les les
dépôts les dépôts fiduciaires par
exemple donc qui auraient besoin de
modifier la nature de leurs avoirs pour
éviter cette taxation donc voilà il y a
un projet qui consistera et qui consista
à identifier les personnes qui se verrai
pénalisé par cette
euh par cette réglementation et à leur
fournir un service donc qui sera
facturable pour ne pas avoir le subir
donc imaginons s'ils avaient eu à payer
euh 10 ils n'auront finalement qu'à
payer 5 mais à la banque pas aux
États et c'est exactement ce ce ce ce ce
type de d'activité à laquelle je me
référais quand quand je parlais de
projet stratégique et de de logique de
de contournement et de de saisi de
d'opportunités commerciales en
l'occurrence lorsque vous avez trouvé
refuge euh en France quelles ont été vos
démarches concrètes pour faire connaître
ces fichiers d'abord euh puisquun récent
rapport de l'Assemblée nationale fait
état d'une certaine déconvenue de de
votre part enfin vous en avez un peu
parl auprès après que laadnif vous a
orienté vers le ministère de l'économie
et des finances quels étaient les
raisons de de cet éconvenu selon vous et
avez-vous été protégé dans dans
l'intervalle et toujours à propos de
l'Assemblée nationale il est indiqué que
vous avez pu regretter que
l'exploitation informatique n'a pas été
aussi approfondi qu'elle aurait pu
qu'elle aurait pu l'être ou dû l'être
est-ce que c'est selon vous exact et
quelle lacune peut-on identifier sur ce
sujet on est resté toujours dans le
sujet hein depuis le début de la séance
euh
maintenant ce que j'ai pu moi euh
constater c'est que déjà au niveau
réglementaire on a on a un problème
parce que si on a besoin aujourd'hui de
lancecur d'alerte c'est qu'au niveau des
témoins on n'a pas une protection
correspondance correspondante à ce qu'il
nécessite ces témoins et euh et tant
qu'on aura pas ça ben il y aura un
manque au niveau euh démocratique et au
niveau de la justice maintenant euh
quand donc j'ai eu à réprouver c'est le
terme est n'est pas vraiment
euh adapté je dirais que j'aurais bien
aimé pouvoir m'adresser directement à la
justice sans avoir besoin de passer par
une commission ratoire internationale
cela dit la France ne le permet pas
toujours pas aujourd'hui c'estd que
aujourd'hui si je me retrouvais en
Suisse avec ces mêmes éléments de preuve
pour une banque dont la dangérosité a
été révélée n'oublions pas que c'est la
banque la plus condamnée de l'histoire
chsbc a
déjà été condamné à hauteur de 1,9
milliards de dollars donc malgré la
dangerusité d' unee banque si
aujourd'hui j'avais ces informations à
transmettre à la justice française je ne
pourrais pas le faire ça me passer par
justement le fait d'être dans le cadre
d'une enquête déjà
ouverte
donc je me suis retrouvé dans les mains
de de l'administration fiscale
probablement parce Queen terme
judiciaair il n'y avait en aucun cas il
n'y a toujours pas l'arsenal qui permet
de faire autrement Arsenal qui existe ne
serait-ce qu'à nos frontières il suffit
d'aller en Espagne on aura un
arsenal qui permet donc de de combler
cette lacune que nous avons ici donc
voilà ça c'est déjà euh pour les euh les
je dirais les les les regrets les la
tristesse que je peux avoir à constater
euh et à revenir sur cette partie de de
de de de mon parcours ensuite pour ce
qui est des moyens pour exploiter les
données plus mieux complètement de façon
utile euh et et et puis en plus
proactive avec une
possibilité d'enclencher un mécanisme
qui nous permettra de rester au niveau
pas simplement de bénéficier d'une
connaissance à un moment T mais aussi
après de garder et d'enrichir cette
connaissence donc tout ça c'est ce dont
j'ai j'ai déjà discuté à savoir ce qui
est à notre portée aujourd'hui c'est un
potentiel donc je regrette que le
précédent gouvernement n'it pas pris les
mesures qu'il était à même
de pouvoir prendre et qu' l'aurait dû
prendre et euh et j'espère et et je je
suis optimiste sur que sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui grâce aussi à vous et
bien on va euh tous ensemble arriver
enfin à proposer quelque chose quelque
chose qui fera que quand on se
retrouvera ou quand on aura l'occasion
de de faire le point sur où on en est on
pourra établir que des avancées auront
été euh effectuées qu'on aura franchi
des pas décisifs
oui on a eu l'occasion d'auditionner
monsieur Parini l'an dernier directeur à
l'époque de la DG FIP et il nous avait
dit que il n'avait pas pu exploiter les
les
fichiers voilà que que pensez-vous de
cette appréciation et avez-vous é
associé à ces travaux avec ày enfin à la
DGF de manière générale alors par
exemple lorsque il y a pas plus tard que
quelques semaines j'ai j'ai
re j'ai recontacté les personnes avec
qui j'avais avait commencé à travailler
il y a de ça 5 ans au niveau de la de la
nef de l'administration fiscale et je
leur j'ai posé une question j'ai dit
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui si on reprenait
depuis le début cette cette aventure
est-ce que vous pensez que nous aurions
travailler ensemble dans un hôtel sur
Nice dans une chambre d'hôtel pour
laquelle rien n'était
prévu dans laquelle rien n'était assuré
ni en terme de sécurité pour ma personne
pour nos personnes né en terme de
sécurité sur les protocoles d'analyse et
de traitement desésinformations
imaginez-vous imaginez-vous traiter la
mémoire d'une banque dans une chambre
d'hôtel c'est ce qu'on a vécu les gens
courageux l'administration fiscale ont
participé à ça bien à leur dépend aussi
bien en en courant des risques et s'il y
avait pas eu euh derrière d'autres
mécanismes pour sécuriser cela moi-même
je me serais pas
soumis mais ça c'est la responsabilité
de qui en tout cas pas des agents qui
ont été soumis c'est au-dessus que les
moyens n'ont pas été réunis pour traiter
le sujet à la mesure qu'il méritait oui
vous dites que nous n'avons pas en
France les moyens que semble-t-il les
Espagnols auraient mais face à au
problème que soulève toute tout tout
cette affaire il y a quand même de deux
techniques l'administration fiscale
certes elle est obligée de passer par la
Commission des infractions fiscales mais
peut déposer plainte pour fraude fiscale
et puis le parquet peut parfaitement
ouvrir directement une enquête voire
après susciter une instruction pour
blanchiment de fraude fiscale puis après
lancer le
processus d'enquête classique avec des
pouvoirs des enquêteurs français qui ne
sont certainement pas moindres que ceux
espagnol je je comprends mal votre
réserve là ou votre critique du système
j'allais dire juridique et bien pardon
oui et bien simplement d'expérience par
rapport à à ce que j'ai pu j'ai pu
vérifier moi-mêmein lorsque je rentre en
contact avec la police judiciaire en
2008 je suis à ce moment encore dans la
banque HSBC d'accord et bien euh ce qui
se ce qui s'opère c'est pas la mise à
disposition de la justice de ces preuves
c'est le fait qu'on me qu'on me fasse
qu'on me mette je dirais en contact avec
les les agents de l'administration
fiscale et qu'on me dise euh nous ne
pouvons pas euh obtenir euh nous
pourrons pas utiliser de façon
judiciaire vos informations n pourrons
pas attester leur origine et nous ne
pourrons les utiliser qu'en terme de
renseignement donc moi je vous fais état
simplement de ce qui sera
établi par euh par les les agents de
l'administration qui qui ont eu en
charge vous nous rapportez ce que ce que
vous avez vécu juridiquement ça me
paraît très contestable je crains que le
choix
soit que ça problème du verif
c'est-à-dire quand il a fraude fiscale
on considère que c'est l'administration
euh qui est compétente et pas euh le
sauf si euh l'administration saisit la
justice et et il me semble que on est
dans non si vous permettez on est on est
avant même c'est cette cette
problématique euh on est dans le fait
que euh si moi je me présente à vous
avec une liste et je dis je suis témoin
de de je je je
je je dirais je vais dénoncer un certain
nombre de faitsacc je suis témoin je
vais dénoncer un nombre de fait bon bref
j'ai une liste je l'écris je n'ai pas
d'autre
responsabilité que que ma parole par
contre si je vous fournis des preuves
des éléments de preuve et que je ne peux
pas tester l'origine de ces preuves vous
pourrez être poursuivi pour
rel si ces éléments sont si vous
utilisez un matériel qui est volé
imaginons vous êtes poursuivi pour
rel et ça on va le modifier et c'est ça
qu'il faut modifier mais c'est
aujourd'hui et moi je vous parle d'il y
a ça 5 ans tout à fait et aujourd'hui
encore avant que cette modification soit
acté nous serons dans la même situation
nous resterons dans la même
situation bien pour pour suivre le le
cheminement encore une fois euh je
demander de rassembler vos souvenirs et
je pense que vous avez une excellente
mémoire et pouvez nous indiquer si des
banques françaises se figuraient parmi
les personnes morales concerné par les
fameuses données puis un rapport de de
l'Assemblée nationale cite certaines
d'entre elles est-ce que vous vous
souvenez de leur de leur identité même
question pour les entreprises non
financière il y avait-il également des
personnalités connues éventuellement des
responsables politiques de premier plan
voilà la première question que je
voulais vous
poser donc euh vous allez comprendre
toujours que mon mon intérêt c'est de se
ramener au mécanisme à à rappeler que
mon ma vraie expertise elle est dans les
mécanismes dans les mécanismes
d'adaptation en l'occurrence de la
banque et c'est là où je vais pouvoir
vraiment contribuer dans toute dans à la
hauteur de tout tout mon potentiel par
contre sur des données qui sont plus du
domaine des clients de la banque des
intermédiaires de la banque et bien ma
contribution se limitera à quoi au fait
de rappeler que la banque fonctionne de
façon distribuée avec une ade
d'intermédiaire ce qui nécessitera pour
nous d'ailleurs de se réunir à plusieurs
de réunir non seulement nos efforts
l'effort de différents ministères
localement mais aussi de se réunir entre
état lorsque donc vous me demandez si
j'ai mémoire de banque je dirais c'est
c'est évident que ce qu'on appellera
l'intermediary banking ça veut dire le
fait qu'une banque détienne de ses avoir
dans d'autres banques et le mécanisme
qui permet d'établir un maillage
entre tout entre une multitude une
myiade d'autres institutions financières
et ça c'est assuré que même sans
regarder même sans avoir jamais
consulter aucune liste ce n'est il est
exclu d'imaginer que donc cette banque
donc Suisse n'est pas de compte ne soit
pas en relation avec des banques
françaises donc et c'est ça le plus
important c'est pas tant forcément que
les banques françaises soient client de
cette banque mais plus que les banques
françaises est comme client cette banque
qui peut présenter aussi donc des des
risques pour nous des des éléments qui
qu'il nous faudra vigiler et et survet
de près donc moi ce que je pense c'est
que la la dangerosité que je vois et la
l'important qu'il y a dans la
connaissance des relations qui existent
entre des banques français et des
banques suisses résident dans la
présence de comptes dans chacune de ces
entités de compte de compte qu'on
appellera miroir ou nostro Lauro et et
ce sont ces maillages effectivement qui
sont qui existent et qui sont répartis
entre plusieurs banques donc vous pouvez
avoir une banque par exemple espagnole
qui aura un compte à une banque
française et euh et Suisse et qui fera
que la banque française sans avoir même
de compte déclaré en Suisse pourra
bénéficier d'un circuit qui qui finira
en Suisse donc les ce ne sera pas
forcément les clients directs simplement
qui présenteront des intérêts mais mais
évidemment vous allez avoir des banques
françaises qui directement aont une
sonont en relation avec les banques
suisses et cette banque là en
l'occurrence vous avez différentes
façons de réaliser ou de concrétiser les
relations qui qui existeront entre
banques donc les les les comptes et les
transactions nous avons aussi les
transactions qui transiteront par
différentes banques par différents
intermédiaires donc c'est tout ce
maillage c'est toute cette complexité
des des moyens de communication
aujourd'hui et des moyens de de relation
et des relations existantes euh qui qui
posent le niveau du défi et
effectivement les banques euh présente
ce ce ce problème alors après quand ça
nous ramène au nom pro au nom par
exemple de personnalité ou euh ou de
ministre il faut pas présumer
que que je dirais un un politique soit
plus bê qu'un autre il ne va pas
forcément déclarer son compte en nom
propre quand nous avons tous les moyens
d'intermédiation qui vous permettront
par exemple de bénéficier de certains
services de de certaines aidees certains
voyage peut-être en bref quand vous
voyez tous les moyens qui vous
permettront euh de d'être rétribué de
façon indirecte
et bien vous allez comprendre qu'il ne
va pas qu'il n'a aucun intérêt à vous
exposer directement à détenir des biens
en Suisse donc plus vous allez être au
fait de ces
intermédiations mieux vous allez
connaître ces mécanismes et moins vous
allez euh vous exposer au fait de
détenir un compte directement ça sera
dans très de dans des mesures vraiment
très infimes que l'on va retrouver des
gens exposés
directement est-ce qu'il y a des comptes
d'entreprises de grosses entreprises
notamment qui ont des des qui sont
concerné par cette l HSBC Private
Banking ce qui peut paraître surprenant
est-ce que vous confirmez quelle est
votre analyse mais évidemment évidemment
si vous voyez par exemple on va revenir
sur les les les logiques d'évitement
vous avez HSBC qui au Luxembourg voyant
le vent tourner au niveau des nom avec
la fadka au nom des personnes qui
déclarent leur nom et bien va céder s
activités de banque privée au Luxembourg
pour se concentrer sur la gestion des
clients qui sont corporate ça ve dire la
partie des entreprises donc c'est c'est
c'est la réponse vous voyez que
aujourd'hui
effectivement
le le secteur économique va se
réorienter vers des
entreprises vers des intermédiaires des
éléments d'intermédiation par rapport au
N personnel au personnes
physiques notre collègue christianat
rapporteur de la commission à
l'Assemblée nationale a fait un travail
de plusieurs mois sur la listesbc et il
faisait état dans la presse récemment de
nombreux salariés d'HSBC plus d'une
centaine de mémoire dont il semblerait à
l'évidence qu'il é des prêtenons pour
d'autres est-ce que vous confirmez cet
état de faite moi encore une fois chaque
cas mérite et nécessite d'être analysé
de façon conséquente quand vous trouver
des employés qui ont des droits des
droits par exemple qui peut être des
droits de regard de signature peut-être
mais avoir il faudra connaître la nature
du compte et la raison pour laquelle
sont détenus ou sont associés au niveau
de certains droits c'est compte s'il
s'agit
imaginez d'un fond de
pension et que l'employé a aussi la
gestion de ce fond de pension il se
verra associé à ce compte bancaire sans
que les avoirs soi réellement à lui
alors si vous parlez de milliers
d'employés bon ça pourrait
être il sera possible que ben on aura en
tout cas une diversité de cas de figure
maintenant je dirais ma connaissance
c'est que la banque fonctionne par
cloisonnement et va éviter de s'exposer
directement je vous dis c'est la la
logique de l'évitement alors ça me
semble quand même euh voilà ça ça ça ça
m'interpelle le fait de penser que des
milliers d'employés soient prêtenant
dans cette banque faudrait voir de plus
près je n'ai pas d'élément aujourd'hui
pour l'établir clairement après c'est
vrai que dans quelques mois peut-être
que je pourrais vous répondre
différemment qu'est-ce qui vous a amener
à à fuir vers l'Espagne à un moment
donné donc quand euh quand euh donc les
élections présidentielles ont permis
monsieur hand donc de de devenir
Président le le vent a
changé les la demande d'entraite
judiciaire formulé par l'Amérique qui
avait
été étouffé qui avait été refusé pendant
de nombreux mois voir des
années repart ça veut dire quelques
semaines simplement quelques semaines
après
l'élection de Monsieur François Hollande
tant que président reprend la
collaboration judiciaire avec l'Amérique
les États-Unis et à ce titre je suis
entendu procureur américain à Paris au
niveau de la section de recherche la
gendie
nationale et on m'indique donc que et
bien malheureusement les les mesures ne
sont pas à même d'être prises je dirais
on avance mais à minima c'est-à-dire que
ils n'auront qu'une partie des des des
informations ils auront eu qu'une partie
de l'aide euh qu'il pouvait espérer de
la justice française à son état à son
moment et euh et c'est pas du domaine de
l'exécutif c'est du domaine de magistrat
à cette époque et qu'est-ce qui s'en
qu'est-ce qu'il en résulte moi je me
retrouve donc à nouveau exposé sans
avoir de mesures de protection adéquate
et euh et les mêmes personnes qui
m'avaient aidé à à sécuriser les les
preuves pour qu'elles puissent être
transmise à la justice ces mêm personnes
euh m'offre un certain nombre d'options
me propose un certain nombre d'options
et celle qui me semble malgré tout pas
la la moins dangereuse mais préférable
par rapport à à à mes convictions et à
mon combat ben c'est de me rendre en
Espagne alors je sais que euh je vais
être
emprisonné mais
euh il faut reconnaître bon dans
certaines mesures qui étai qui sont
avéré bien autres que celles espéré et
donc voilà je c'est pour fuir certaines
menaces pour fuir les risques inérants
au fait que d'un côté
l'entraide reprend de notre
côté peut-être que la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale l'opacité financière
va reprendre et que pendant le temps
qu'elle reprenne moi je ne serai pas
n'étant pas protégé je serai exposer
donc c'est dans cette condition dans ces
conditions dans ce contexte que je
prends la décision effectivement de me
rendre en Espagne votre commentaire sur
Le ce qui vient d'arriver Monsieur
Pierre Condamin Gerbier votre collègue
qui a été auditionné ici même le 12 juin
dernier et donc les autorités suisses
viennent de l'incarcérer c'est bien cela
il fait mesure voilà la justice s'empare
de son cas quel est votre commentaire
sur cette situation ben mon commentaire
c'est que bon je ne connais pas déjà
cette personne mais ce qui est certain
c'est que toute personne qui participe à
la la justice donc jusqu'à preuve du
contraire hein il il s'est présenté à la
justice il est devenu un témoin pour des
enquêtes en cour dans au niveau de la
justice française et qu'est-ce que je
vois c'est couper l'herbre couper
l'herbre sur le pied de la justice
française donc quelle est la démarche
quel est le le fond de cette démarche de
la justice suisse dans dans ce dossier
c'est vraiment empêcher une instruction
qui est en développement sur le
territoire français euh ça c'est factuel
indépendant de la personne moi je je ne
peux pas je ne connais pas même la
nature des des informations qu'il qu'il
a transmise la le le témoignage qu'il a
à à transmettre mais je sais que c'est
un témoin et en tant que témoin dans une
procédure française je pense que n'étant
pas en guerre avec la Suisse on pourrait
s'attendre à une meilleure collaboration
des
justices sur votre départ en Espagne
vous vous
dites mettez le micro là par contre sur
le votre départ en Espagne vous indiquez
que ayant pris conscience avec la
collaboration Franco USA que vous ne
seriez pas à même en fr d'avoir toutes
les garanties d'aller le plus loin
possible dans l'exploitation de ce que
vous avez observé vous mettez en exerg
la le danger que ça pourrait avoir pour
vous mais est-ce qu'il y a aussi un le
fait que la justice espagnol et les
mécanismes de travail de l'Espagne vous
permettaiit de continuer un travail
d'investigation et de d'aller vers un un
traitement judiciaire des choses ou
est-ce que c'était uniquement lié aux
menaces que vous sentiez potentiellement
sur vous évidemment plusieurs plusieurs
paramètres ont ont influé mon
choix parmi les les paramètres je
pourrais simplement constater que
lorsque fut nommé
donc au ministère du Budget monsieur
Cahusac pour moi la la tournure des
événements ne me semblait pas tout à
fait
favorable ne serait-ce que sous cet axe
maintenant il y en a d'autres il y a
effectivement
le fait que un certain nombre de de de
démarches avec des informations à minima
avaient été mené en Espagne avec succès
des personnes de plus haut niveau il
faut rappeler que Monsieur bottine donc
qui est vraiment le le représentant de
la plus puissante banque européenne à ce
jour là saendeur avait été reconnu
coupable donc d'évasion pour plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros donc il
fallait comprendre il fallait restituer
il faut aujourd'hui c'est même
l'occasion aussi d'insister là-dessus
vous avez des dirigeants au plus haut
niveau des plus grandes instances
bancaires
européenne qui pratique l'évasion
fiscale déjà donc ça ça a été effectué
et c'est un résultat à qui en Espagne
par l'Espagne donc c'est un des facteurs
un des paramètres qui a influé dans mon
choix ensuite bon ben je
pourrais les les énumérer il y aura
effectivement le fait que je m'attendais
pas non plus à passer 5 mois en prison
quand on sait que dans le cas je vous ai
parlé des frères nmy qui s'agit quand
même de blanchiment d'argent de
narcotrafiquant hein et bien la personne
a été condamnée à 6 mois de
prison donc je sais pas combien de mois
elle l'aura fait mais donc voilà on a
dans quel pay vous avez été emprisonné
monsieur FCI en Espagne d' en Espagne en
Espagne sous pourquoi sur à la la
demande euh B de la banque hein de la
chsbc qui qui a demandé donc par
l'Interpol à ce que donc je sois extradé
vers vers la
Suisse pour des motifs là alors si on y
revenz aussi c'est une parenthèse si que
si vous m permettez ben je pourrais
faire faut voir que on a prétexté à la
justice suisse entre autres d'autres
mensonges que je n'avais pas que je je
n'avais pas été disponible pour
participer à leur enquête qui s'était
déroulé déjà depuis 5 ans sachant qu'ils
avaient toujours eu mon adresse mon
téléphone personnel pour me joindre à
tout instant par mon intermé et
intermédiaire de mes avocats qui
m'avaent convié à une visite en février
2012 sur territoire suisse où je m'étais
rendu donc quand on voit tous ces
éléments et quand on réalise donc que il
s'adresse à une autre justice en
prétextant que déjà ils avaient besoin
de m'extrader parce queil n'avait pas
possibilité de rentrer en contact avec
moi pour faire progresser l'enquête on
voit bien dans quel contexte on se situe
on voit bien quelle est la la la
gravité la gravité de la situation quand
on arrive à ce que des des représentants
d'une justice se comportent de telle
façon donc bon au résultat voilà je me
suis retrouvé emprisonné pour ces motifs
dans un cadre où la justice espagnoleah
finalement a a rempli son rôle et et
dans tous les dans tous les axes par
rapport à ses engagements elle pour le
coup elle a rempli ses engagements
européens internationaux et elle a aussi
rempli son rôle en me permettant d'aider
la justice dans le cadre donc du parquet
anticorruption donc en y allant j'étais
pas assuré de pouvoir amener ma
contribution aussi à au parquet
anticorruption il s'avérait que ce fut
ible et et j'en j'en suis ravi bon le
coup a été rude le coup reste rude mais
mais c'est ainsi c'est c'est
effectivement au regard donc de toute
cette de tout ce contexte de de ce poids
il faut comprendre que aujourd'hui je je
représente une menace une grande menace
par rapport à quoi par rapport au bien
le plus précieux de de de la plupart de
ces banques privées qui est leur
réputation donc ma simple personne le
simple fait que vous me receviez ici le
simple fait que ça
se que ça se continue par la suite qu'on
maintienne la pression et qu'on engage
des des moyens pour lutter et bien va
affaiblir
naturellement ces
activités je dirais qui sont
répréhensibles vis-à-vis de nos intérêts
donc c'est c'est tout cette c'est tout
cette poids c'est tout ce poids c'est
tout ce potentiel là qui a fait qu'à un
moment donné il a fallu que je pense à
sécuriser ma
personne alors quelques dernières
questions parce que nous approchons de
l'heure de l'audition suivante et je
vrais pas prendre de retard donc vous
venez en gros de nous expliquer que
l'exploitation total et intégral de la
liste de fin du fichier n'a pas été
accompli si j'ai bien compris des
systèmes des informations disponibles
sur la banque est-ce que vous AZ
travaillé encore aujourd'hui avec est-ce
que vous vous avez vous y avez travaillé
d'autres pays je pense à la Grèce le
royaume par exemple est-ce que vous AZ
travaillé encore aujourd'hui à
l'exploitation de de ces systèmes et
pensez-vous qu'il faille enfin imaginons
une autorité indépendante une équipe
d'experts indépendant et transparent qui
aurait la tâche de de travailler
jusqu'au fond de justement de
l'exploitation de ces systèmes est-ce
que ça serait utile nécessaire et
notamment du point de vue de l'intégrité
de la liste parce que la question est
revenue à plusieurs reprise dès
l'audition ici du procureur de
montolfier qui se posait la question
comme beaucoup d'autres personnes donc
pensez-vous cette intégrité est été
préservée parce que la liste a quand
même circulé entre beaucoup de mains
depuis sa transmission jusqu'à
l'exploitation aujourd'hui et pour la
suite voilà donc qu'est-ce qui a pu se
passer entre deux pensez-vous que
l'intégrité de cette de ces fichiers est
été vraiment respectter et dernière
question plus personnelle vous l'avez
évoqué vous parlez de menace à votre
endroit de de quel type de menace
d'abord et de de la part de qui euh
proviennent-ell donné ce qui est
essentiel de de bien comprendre
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mesure
d'assurer l'intégrité des données et
d'assurer qu' auront été ou pas tronqués
par telle ou telle administration
pourquoi parce que par le par le même
mécanisme que les informations auront
été disponibles et mis dans les mains de
la justice français les mêmes
informations qui ont été transmises à la
justice française ont été transmises à
la justice espagnol ce qui permettra
donc de les comparer et d'établir qu'il
n'y a pas d'altération qu'il n'y a pas
eu
euh de modification de ces information
la justice suisse également la justice
suisse aussi donc on aura déjà la
possibilité de d'assurer qu'il n'y a pas
eu
d'altération mais là je vous dis je je
je préfère donc me reconcentrer sur le
fait que déjà en France et en Espagne
avant même euh la l'acceptation de la
collaboration judiciaire les deux
entités cont posséd les informations euh
des informations identiques donc le
rapprochement pourra être effectué il
pourra lever le doute lever le doute
aussi sur quoi sur
euh sur sur justement des des
informations qui ont été
euh qui ont été je dirais tronqué qui
ont été dévoyés euh sur le fait que des
fichiers onent été modifiés il y a un
rapport de la justice euh Suisse qui
disait qui révélait que les données dé
fichiers auraient été altérées et là il
faut bien comprendre la différence qu'il
y a entre
l'intégrité
l'identité matérielle et logique d'
d'une information si vous avez un film
un film vidéo que vous le copiez ben
vous aurez la sur cette copie la
préservation de l'intégrité logique de
ces informations par contre physiquement
effectivement non ce ne sera pas le même
physique donc ce qu'avait euh soulever
le les
autorités suisses avait été justement
une modification en terme physique sur
certains fichiers qui n'ont jamais été
exploités jusqu'ici de surcroix mais par
contre ces ces altération physique qui
pouvait révéler peut-être ne serait-ce
que une copie hein ne permettait en
aucun cas d'attester d'une altération
logique donc ça c'est aussi c'est une
notion importante qu'il qu'il convient
de partager aujourd'hui euh ensuite donc
vous avez posé un certain nombre de
questions il y avait aussi donc la
possibilité donc de poursuivre la lutte
ben oui je le répète la possibilité de
poursuivre la lutte elle existe
d'exploiter ces informations elle existe
et d'aller au-delà c'est-à-dire ces
informations ont surtout à mon sens
l'intérêt de révéler la dynamicité de la
banque de la de la diversité des outils
dont elle dispose pour pouvoir justement
contourner les réglementation mais donc
faisant état de cela il s'agit pas de
s'arrêter à cela seul il s'agit donc de
mettre en place les mécanismes qui vont
nous permettre de faire face à cela et
je suis je suis optimiste sur le fait
qu'on y arrive et je sais que on est
déjà en contact pour essayer que tous
ensemble avec ma contribution on arrive
justement à constituer quelque chose
d'efficace et de
correspondant aux enjeux enfin pour ma
menace donc elle est elle est aussi
tributaire de cela c'estàdire que ayant
euh un gouvernement qui qui veut lutter
qui cherche réellement à lutter contre
l'évasion fiscal contre la l'opacité
financière et bien en étant un acteur
qui va permettre justement de donner un
avantage dans cette lutte qui représente
un avantage dans cette lutte tant que je
resteraiis un élément assez unique assez
euh assez marginal ben je serai exposé à
un risque et donc dès que on rentrera
dans euh une démarche qui sera plus
étatique où on aura des structures
correspondantes conséquentes alors là
les risques sur ma personne seront
diminués évidemment je pourrais rester
peut-être emblématique sur certains
points parce que justement peut-être que
si je me projette avec optimisme ben je
serai peut-être un des éléments
déterminants dans cette euh constitution
d'une force de défense mais malgré tout
je dirais le le risque sera moindre
parce que euh nous serons sur un pied
qui sera plus d'égalité et je ne
représenterai pas la marginalité qui
risque d'être le
déclenchement bah quoi de d'un mécanisme
de défense est-ce que vous avez été
approché et je conclurai là-dessus par
les autorités de supervision françaises
l'autorité de contrôle prudentielle et
l'Autorité des marchés financiers je
n'ai jusqu'à mon retour d'Espagne la
seule et unique personne en dehors de
l'administration fiscale hein la nef et
la justice qui qui m'a qui m'apoché la
seule autorité qui qui met
approché a été Monsieur Arnaud
montebourgb seule personne qui a donc en
terme d'autorité qui qui a qui s'est
intéressé à ce qui se passait dans le
fond a été monsieur Arna de monondbourg
donc je n'étais je n'ai jusqu'ici pas
encore été approché par tout autre
entité prudentielle
ou bien monsieur merci beaucoup pour
cette audition qui se termine mercici à
vous
voilà vous avez donc pu réécouter
l'audition d'Hervé falseni devant la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur le
rôle des banques dans l'évasion fiscale
tout de suite la suite de nos programmes
sur Public
Sénat